This episode is brought to you by FedEx. These days, the Power Move isn't having a big metallic credit card to drop on the check at a corporate lunch. The real Power Move is leveling up your business with FedEx intelligence. And accessing one of the biggest data networks powered by one of the biggest delivery networks. Level up your business with FedEx, the new Power Move. In communities across Canada, hourly Amazon employees can grow their skills and their paycheck by enrolling in free skills training programs for in-demand fields. Learn more at aboutamazon.ca. The Mongol Empire is invading our home.
本期节目由联邦快递（FedEx）赞助播出。如今，所谓的“强力之举”（Power Move）不再是企业午餐时掏出一张沉甸甸的金属信用卡来结账。真正的“强力之举”是利用联邦快递的智能服务提升您的业务水平，并接入由全球最大物流网络之一所驱动的庞大数据网络。选择联邦快递，提升您的业务，这就是全新的“强力之举”。在加拿大各地的社区，亚马逊的计时员工可以通过参加免费的紧缺领域技能培训项目，提升技能并增加收入。详情请访问 aboutamazon.ca。蒙古帝国正在入侵我们的家园。
They are brutal, relentless, unstoppable. We are 80 samurai against an army fighting to slow the influence. invasion. Today, I die for my people. There must be thousands of the enemy. We will face death and defend our home. Tradition, courage, honor, they are what make us. We are the warriors of Tsushima. We are samurai. Thank you. Thank you. So that is the opening
他们残暴、无情、势不可挡。我们只有80名武士，面对着一支试图削弱我们影响力的军队。入侵开始了。今天，我为我的人民而死。敌人恐怕有数千之众。我们将直面死亡，保卫家园。传统、勇气、荣誉，这些造就了我们。我们是对马岛的武士。我们是武士。谢谢。谢谢。这就是那部优秀电子游戏《对马岛之魂》的开场，
to the excellent video game, Ghost of Tsushima, which was developed by an American company, Sucker Punch Productions for Sony, in 2020. And as anyone who's played the game will know, we're in the 13th century in 1274. So the antagonists are the Mongols,
该游戏由美国公司 Sucker Punch Productions 为索尼开发，于2020年发行。正如玩过这款游戏的人所知，故事背景设定在13世纪的1274年。所以，反派是蒙古人，
who are ruling a mighty empire, stretching all the way from the Danube to the peninsula of Korea, and their next target is Japan. And a huge Mongol armada is on the way. And the first stop in its sights is Tsushima, which is the island that lies midway between Korea and Western Japan. And in the game, you are playing as Jin Sakai. So your task is to resist the Mongol assault.
他们统治着一个强大的帝国，疆域从多瑙河一直延伸到朝鲜半岛，而他们的下一个目标是日本。一支庞大的蒙古舰队正在赶来。他们的第一个目标是对马岛，也就是位于朝鲜半岛和日本西部之间的一座岛屿。在游戏中，你扮演的是境井仁。所以你的任务是抵抗蒙古人的进攻。
And you are a young nobleman of Tsushima. And you've been instructed in the way of the samurai by your uncle, Lord. Shimura, who is the person speaking in that prologue. And in fact, one of the things you have to do in the game is to slightly ignore Shemura's advice because you're playing as a ghost, a kind of assassin. Because Shemura says to you at the beginning, Jin, when we fight, we face our enemy head on. And when we take their life, we look them in the eye with courage and respect. This is what makes us samurai. But whether Jin he hides that advice or whether he goes his own way is what the game is about, isn't it, Tom? You're such a big video games fan. I'm amazed you started this with such a
你是一位年轻的对马岛贵族。你曾受教于你的叔叔志村大人，他就是序幕中说话的那个人。事实上，你在游戏中必须要做的一件事，就是稍微违背志村大人的建议，因为你扮演的是“战鬼”，一种刺客。因为志村在开头对你说：“仁，当我们战斗时，我们要正面迎敌。当我们夺取他们的生命时，我们要怀着勇气和尊重直视他们的双眼。这就是我们身为武士的准则。”但仁是听从了建议，还是走上了自己的路，这正是游戏的主题，不是吗，汤姆？你是个超级电子游戏迷。我很惊讶你竟然以这么
long discussion about Ghost of Tsushima. I mean, it's an excellent choice. But I'm guessing you've never played it. I looked at it on YouTube. I thought it looked quite good, quite exciting. And I wanted to do that, partly because the samurai are such a part of kind of video game culture. Am I right in saying that? I think I am. Yeah. I mean, there's lots of samurai video games. But it's also because that opening that you gave, It's expressive of a very distinctive take, a very distinctive understanding of the samurai. The actual reality, the historical context, you know, what actually happened when the Mongols landed at Sashima, they then go on to attack mainland Japan. We will be coming to that later in this year.
长的关于《对马岛之魂》的讨论作为开场。我的意思是，这是一个绝佳的选择。但我猜你从来没玩过它。我在 YouTube 上看过。我觉得它看起来很不错，很刺激。我想这样做，部分原因是武士在某种程度上是电子游戏文化的一部分。我说得对吗？我想是的。是的，有很多关于武士的电子游戏。但这也是因为你刚才提到的那个开场，它表达了一种非常独特的视角，一种对武士非常独特的理解。实际的现实，历史背景，你知道，当蒙古人登陆对马岛时，他们随后继续进攻日本本土，这到底发生了什么。我们今年晚些时候会讲到。
We're not going to be doing that in this series, because in this series, we're going back to look at the beginnings of the samurai, the origins of this extraordinary warrior cast. And it's a story that will be taking us to the heart of medieval. So we'll be going to the 10th, the 11th centuries, when this very distinctive class of warrior starts to emerge on the Japanese archipelago. We'll be looking particularly at the eruption in the late 12th century of this massive civil war between rival samurai clans. And this is a conflict that inspired the great epic of medieval Japan, the kind of the
我们在这个系列中不会讲到那些，因为在这个系列中，我们要回顾武士的起源，这个非凡武士阶层的起源。这是一个将带我们走进中世纪核心的故事。所以我们将回到10世纪和11世纪，当时这种非常独特的武士阶层开始在日本列岛出现。我们将特别关注12世纪末，敌对武士氏族之间爆发的那场大规模内战。这是一场激发了日本中世纪伟大史诗的冲突，那种
Iliad of Japan, which is a work called The Tale of the Heike. And we will also be exploring the way in which the rise of military rule, the rise of this warrior cast, results in the eclipse of the traditional court life focused in Kyoto, the great imperial capital. So it's a series about a cast of warriors who rank, I would say, as perhaps the most glamorous and mythologized warriors of all time. Yeah, loads of our listeners will have a vague impression of the samurai, I would imagine. They'll imagine the sort of the drawn swords and the tremendous armour and stuff. But I'm guessing a lot of people have only the very flimsyest idea of exactly when they were around and where they came from. Right. And I think because they are so mythologised, it's probably worthwhile before we actually start the chronological sweep of this series,
日本的《伊利亚特》，也就是一部名为《平家物语》的作品。我们还将探讨军事统治的兴起，即这个武士阶层的崛起，是如何导致以京都这一伟大帝国首都为中心的传统宫廷生活走向衰落的。所以这是一个关于武士阶层的系列，我会说，他们或许是史上最迷人、最被神话的战士。是的，我想我们很多听众对武士都有一个模糊的印象。他们会想象那种拔出的刀剑、精美的盔甲之类的东西。但我猜很多人对他们到底是什么时候出现的、从哪里来的，只有最模糊的概念。没错。而且我认为，因为他们被如此神话，在我们开始这个系列的年代梳理之前，
go back to the beginnings of how and why the samurai emerge. think it's worth giving listeners a sense of the broad sweep of their history so that we can put their emergence in an overall context. So as you say, if you shut your eyes, if you imagine a samurai, I think the image is likely to be that of a warrior vaguely situated in the Middle Ages. So actually someone like Jin Sakai in Ghost of Sashima. But the thing about the samurai, and this is what makes some difference, say, from other very mythologised classes of warrior like Vikings, say, the knights of medieval Christendom. These are medieval warriors who actually outlast the Middle Ages. And I think that this is why in the West as well as I would guess in Japan, their aesthetic,
回顾武士是如何以及为何出现的起源，是非常值得的。我认为有必要让听众对他们的历史概貌有一个了解，这样我们才能把他们的出现放在一个整体背景中。正如你所说，如果你闭上眼睛，想象一个武士，我想这个形象很可能是一个模糊地处于中世纪的战士。就像《对马岛之魂》里的境井仁那样。但关于武士的一点，也是这使他们区别于其他被高度神话的战士阶层（比如维京人，或者中世纪基督教世界的骑士）的地方，在于他们是中世纪的战士，但实际上活过了中世纪。我认为这就是为什么在西方，以及我想在日本也是如此，他们的审美，
the sense of them as having kind of moral codes, their vibe, if you want to put it like that, can actually seem much more attuned to contemporary culture than say those of Harold Hardrada, the great Viking warrior or the black prince, the flower of medieval chivalry. And I think that this in turn underlies a further paradox about the standing of the samurai in the imagination, which is that on the one hand, they are indelibly Japanese. They are up there with geisha and with tea ceremonies and sumo and all that kind of thing as absolutely kind of a list markers of Japanese culture. A samurai is Japan. But at the same time, they have also become global icons.
他们那种拥有某种道德准则的感觉，或者如果你愿意这么说的话，他们的“氛围”，实际上可能比哈拉尔德·哈德拉达（伟大的维京战士）或黑太子（中世纪骑士精神的典范）更符合当代文化。我认为这反过来又揭示了武士在想象中地位的另一个悖论，即一方面，他们是不可磨灭的日本符号。他们与艺伎、茶道、相扑等一起，作为日本文化的绝对标志，位列榜首。武士就是日本。但与此同时，他们也成为了全球偶像。
They are objects of a universal fascination. So when you did that opening to the ghost of Sashima, your accent was a kind of American-Japanese fusion, which is kind of what the samurai has become. Yeah, and there's something also slightly, not exactly timeless, but the samurai have been detached from their epochs so that they can often see something very science fiction about the samurai. So the samurai's influence on Star Wars, for example, is a very... case and point, which is something you'll be discussing. This is brilliantly illustrated in a show that's on at the British Museum at the moment about the samurai. And you walk into this show and the very first exhibit beautifully lit is this incredibly eerie suit of armour. So you have a helmet. It's complete with a face mask. It's got a dragon's head over the brows. And coming from the back of the helmet,
他们是普遍迷恋的对象。所以当你做《对马岛之魂》的那个开场时，你的口音是一种美日融合的风格，这正是武士所演变的样子。是的，而且还有一些稍微，不完全是永恒，但武士已经脱离了他们的时代，所以武士身上往往能看到非常科幻的东西。例如，武士对《星球大战》的影响就是一个非常典型的例子，这也是你将要讨论的内容。大英博物馆目前正在举办的一个关于武士的展览非常精彩地说明了这一点。你走进这个展览，第一个展品灯光布置得很美，是一套令人毛骨悚然的盔甲。你有一个头盔。它配有面具。眉间有一个龙首。从头盔后面延伸出来的，
there are these golden leaves that look very sinister. They're like kind of blades. There's a the iron cuirass, there are thigh guards that are laced with silk, there are sleeves and shin guards that are lined with silk. And the various parts of this outfit come from the 16th and 17th centuries. And so this is the look of the samurai on the cusp of the great transformation in Japan's history. And this is its redemption from what had been almost 200 years of internecine civil war fighting between warrior clans that had spanned the whole of the 15th and 16th. centuries and is known as the age of the warring states after a similar period of war in Chinese history. And then in 1603, a single warlord finally manages to establish his supremacy
是那些看起来非常阴森的金色叶片。它们就像某种刀刃。有一件铁胸甲，有丝绸系带的腿甲，还有丝绸内衬的袖子和护胫。这套装备的各个部分来自16世纪和17世纪。所以这就是日本历史上大变革前夕武士的样子。这是对几乎200年内战的救赎，那是跨越了整个15和16世纪的武士氏族间的战斗，被称为“战国时代”，类似于中国历史上的类似战争时期。然后在1603年，一位军阀终于成功确立了他的霸权，
over the whole of Japan. He defeats all his kind of the rival warlords. And this is a man called Tokugawa Yeyasu. And he, for those who have seen Shogun, the wonderfully good Disney series set in the year 1600. This is the model for Lord Torinaga, who will likewise in Shogun emerge as the Shogun. And the title is Shogun. So Shogun is an ancient title, isn't it? Or at least in its full version, it's an ancient title. And it's basically a great general or warlord who subdues barbarians. Isn't that right? Yes. So it's actually, it's a little bit like imperato, the word that Scipio-Africanus was given. So it's a victorious general who's triumphed over kind of barbarians, as you say. In Japanese, this word shogun has a very classy pedigree. It goes right
统治了整个日本。他击败了他所有的敌对军阀。这个人叫德川家康。对于那些看过《幕府将军》的人来说，这部设定在1600年的精彩迪士尼剧集，这就是“吉井虎永”大人的原型，他同样会在《幕府将军》中成为幕府将军。而头衔就是“将军”。所以“将军”是一个古老的头衔，对吧？或者至少在它的完整版本中，它是一个古老的头衔。它基本上是一个征服野蛮人的伟大将军或军阀。不是这样吗？是的。所以它实际上有点像“统帅”（Imperator），即西庇阿·阿非利加努斯获得的那个词。所以它是一位战胜了某种野蛮人的胜利将军，正如你所说。在日语中，这个词“将军”有着非常高贵的血统。它一直
the way back to the earliest days of the Japanese state, which is a period when, so the geography of Japan is going to be quite important in this story. So if you think of the main island of Japan, the central island, Honshu, there's a great kind of block of mountains right running through the middle of it. And about 75% of Japan is mountainous. And on the western side of the western side of that, it's all civilized. This is where the Japanese imperial state is centered in the early Middle Ages, and north of this great block of mountains. So in northeastern Honshu, this in the early middle ages is full of what are called by the Japanese barbarians. And so generals get sent from Kyoto, the Great Imperial Court, to go and fight these barbarians in the kind of the northern
追溯到日本国家的最早期，这是一个时期，所以日本的地理在这个故事中将非常重要。所以如果你想到日本的主岛，中心岛屿本州岛，中间有一大片山脉贯穿。日本大约75%的土地是山地。而在那片山脉的西侧，一切都是文明的。这就是日本帝国在中世纪早期集中的地方，而在那片大山脉的北面。所以本州东北部，在中世纪早期，到处都是日本人所说的“野蛮人”。因此，将军们从京都（伟大的帝国宫廷）被派往北方，去与这些野蛮人作战。
wilds. And Tokugawa Yeyasu, by taking this title of Shogun, is deliberately legitimized. his regime by drawing on these kind of ancient traditions. It's a very familiar story. A radical revolutionary new form of government dignifies and disguises its radicalism beneath a show of tradition. So effectively, Tokugawa is now the head of government. He runs the state. But legally, like the generals back in the early Middle Ages, he is ranking as a servant of
而德川家康通过采用“将军”这个头衔，故意通过利用这些古老的传统来使他的政权合法化。这是一个非常熟悉的故事。一种激进的革命性新政府形式，在传统的掩护下尊严化并掩盖了它的激进性。所以实际上，德川现在是政府首脑。他管理国家。但在法律上，就像中世纪早期的将军们一样，他的地位是天皇的臣子。
the emperor. That is the kind of the legal situation. And the regime that Tokugawa establishes and which is run by his descendants endures for two and a half centuries. So right the way up until the middle of the 19th century. And throughout that entire period, Japan remains at peace. So you've had 200 years of kind of savage war, warlords tearing chunks out of each other, and then you have two and a half centuries of stability and order. But the mad thing is, well, maybe it's not mad.
这就是法律上的情况。德川建立并由其后代管理的政权持续了两个半世纪。一直持续到19世纪中叶。而在整个那段时期，日本保持了和平。所以你经历了200年的野蛮战争，军阀们互相残杀，然后你有了两个半世纪的稳定和秩序。但疯狂的是，嗯，也许这并不疯狂。
I mean, maybe it's reflective of the settlement that Tokugawa has arrived at. Throughout this period of peace, the samurai are effectively functioning as bureaucrats, as civilians, but they never give up their military status. The shogunate is always casting itself as a military regime. So the samurai, the warriors, are less than 10% of the population in all, but they rank as the kind of the upper class. the kind of the most prestigious cast, if you want to put it that way, because it's almost impossible to become a samurai except by birth. And even though they are basically spending their
我的意思是，也许这反映了德川达成的和解。在整个和平时期，武士实际上是作为官僚、作为平民在运作，但他们从未放弃他们的军事地位。幕府总是将自己塑造为一个军事政权。所以武士，这些战士，总共不到人口的10%，但他们被列为上层阶级。如果你愿意这么说的话，他们是最负盛名的阶层，因为除了出身之外，几乎不可能成为武士。尽管他们基本上把时间花在
time, you know, organizing, I don't know, corvays or roads or whatever, they're functioning as civilians, they are obliged to maintain a kind of nominal state of military readiness. And the grander you are as a samurai, the better your birth, the more you are expected to kind cosplay as a lord from the era of the warring states. So there is an element of dressing up and role-playing about this, isn't a deliberate, self-conscious role-playing, almost? Yeah, I mean, it's as though in the Victorian House of Lords, the Lords had to come dressed in armour.
组织，我不知道，徭役或道路建设之类的事务上，他们作为平民在运作，但他们有义务保持一种名义上的军事准备状态。而且你作为武士的地位越高，出身越好，你就越被期望去扮演战国时代的领主。所以这其中有一种装扮和角色扮演的成分，不是吗？一种刻意的、自觉的角色扮演？是的，我的意思是，就好像在维多利亚时代的上议院，议员们必须穿着盔甲出席一样。
Yeah. It's important to the image of the samurai that they are ready in case, you know, a repeat of the Mongol attack happens or something like that. Right. So samurai lords are brought up to ride a horse. to shoot arrows from horseback. Of course, the swordsmanship, the katana, the famous Japanese sword with its curved blade and, you know, you have the hilt that you hold with two hands, and you wear it blade up at the waist. You know, the armour originates in the period of
是的。武士的形象很重要的一点是，他们随时准备着，以防蒙古人的袭击再次发生之类的事件。没错。所以武士领主从小就被教导骑马。从马背上射箭。当然，剑术，武士刀，那把著名的带有弯曲刀刃的日本剑，你知道，你用双手握住刀柄，把它刀刃向上佩戴在腰间。你知道，盔甲起源于
the warring state. So the breastplates, the shin guards, the metal masks, the helmets. And these helmets are adorned with really spectacular markers of identity, Crescent Moon's wings, animal heads. So this is basically the armour that you see at the opening of the British Museum show. And as you say, they are playing the part of medieval warriors with all this stuff. And at the same time as they are dressing up in their spectacular helmets and practicing their horsemanship and learning to fire bow and arrow, in the outside world, and particularly the Western world, life goes on. And certainly in Europe, people are pretty oblivious. to Japan. And this is because Japan has shut itself off. So there is one isolated factory that is on
战国时代。所以胸甲、护胫、金属面具、头盔。而这些头盔装饰着非常壮观的身份标志，新月、翅膀、动物头颅。所以这基本上就是你在大英博物馆展览开幕时看到的盔甲。正如你所说，他们正在扮演中世纪战士的角色，带着所有这些东西。与此同时，当他们穿着壮观的头盔，练习骑术，学习射箭时，在外部世界，特别是西方世界，生活还在继续。当然在欧洲，人们对日本几乎一无所知。这是因为日本已经自我封闭了。所以有一个孤立的工厂位于
an island of Nagasaki in the southwest of Japan. And this is run by the Dutch, and the Dutch are the only Europeans who are allowed to have a presence on Japanese soil. So by the 19th century, Europeans have effectively been banned from Japan for over 200 years. And then in 1853, it all changes because a US Commodore called Matthew Perry sails into what come to be called Tokyo Bay at the head of four menacing ships, as it seems to the Japanese, four black ships, they're called. Yeah, the black ships.
日本西南部的长崎的一个岛上。这是由荷兰人经营的，荷兰人是唯一被允许在日本领土上存在的欧洲人。所以到了19世纪，欧洲人实际上已经被禁止进入日本200多年了。然后在1853年，一切都改变了，因为一位名叫马修·佩里的美国海军准将，率领四艘在日本人看来充满威胁的船只，驶入了后来被称为东京湾的地方，它们被称为“黑船”。是的，黑船。
And the Americans, they've got their guns and their cannon and everything. So they are able to force a hearing from the shogunate and they land in Edo, as it's called, the great city. And they find something that seems to them completely wild, which is this fantastical land where history seems to have been put on hold. It seems like the Middle Ages are still kind of running. I mean, this isn't entirely the case. So it's often said that the Shogunate banned firearms, for instance.
美国人带着他们的枪支、大炮和一切装备。所以他们能够强迫幕府听取他们的要求，他们登陆了江户，也就是那个伟大的城市。他们发现了一些在他们看来完全疯狂的东西，这是一个奇幻的土地，历史似乎被按下了暂停键。看起来中世纪似乎还在继续。我的意思是，这并不完全是事实。所以人们常说幕府禁止了枪支，例如。
This isn't true. What they do is to regulate the use of firearms very, very strictly. So it often seemed to European visitors that they weren't firearms. There were, but it's undoubtedly the case that Japan compared, say, to the industrializing states of Europe or the United States in the middle of the 19th century. It does seem really, really weird. This land ruled by a kind of medieval order of warriors in the age of the steam train and the telegraph and battleships and all of that.
这不是真的。他们所做的是非常非常严格地管制枪支的使用。所以欧洲游客往往觉得他们没有枪支。其实是有枪支的，但毫无疑问，与19世纪中叶欧洲或美国的工业化国家相比，日本确实显得非常非常奇怪。这片土地由一种中世纪的战士阶层统治，而当时已经是蒸汽火车、电报和战列舰的时代了。
But now that Commodore Perry has arrived in Tokyo Bay and kind of open Japan up to the world, this is very bad news for the rule of the samurai, because they're going to force Japan to open up. And this is not good news for, you know, ancient medieval warriors. No, no. And there's a good, there's a nice book on people who are interested, a sort of short history of Japan by Christopher Harding, isn't it? He's been on the show during the World Cup. And he has a story about a load of samurai, going to America, which perfectly captures the kind of culture clash, doesn't it? Is that 1860? Yeah, so it's the first embassy that goes from Japan to a Western country, and it's taken on an American ship across the Pacific. They land in San Francisco,
但现在佩里准将已经抵达东京湾，并以某种方式向世界开放了日本，这对武士的统治来说是非常坏的消息，因为他们将强迫日本开放。这对古老的中世纪战士来说不是好消息。不，不。对于感兴趣的人来说，有一本好书，克里斯托弗·哈丁写的《日本简史》，不是吗？他在世界杯期间上过我们的节目。他讲了一个关于一群武士去美国的故事，这完美地捕捉到了那种文化冲突，不是吗？那是1860年吗？是的，这是日本派往西方国家的第一个使团，它是乘坐一艘美国船只横跨太平洋的。他们抵达旧金山，
and they find everything about America bewildering. So there's a tremendous account of the samurai having their first American food. And it's like a Frenchman arriving in England. So the Samurai, the head of the samurai says the hardship cannot adequately be described by paying. I imagine all these kind of burgers and stuff. That terrible bacon the Americans have. And the cheese. The cheese, mad cheese. Like, when you've got so many agricultural resources, why would your cheese be so pitiful?
他们发现关于美国的一切都令人困惑。所以有一个关于武士第一次吃美国食物的精彩记录。这就像一个法国人抵达英国。所以武士，武士的首领说，这种苦难无法用言语来形容。我想象着所有这些汉堡之类的东西。美国人那种糟糕的培根。还有奶酪。奶酪，疯狂的奶酪。就像，当你拥有如此多的农业资源时，为什么你的奶酪会如此可怜？
And don't text us about Wisconsin cheddar, like, because you just barely can get that. An enduring mystery, which the samurai puzzled over as well. And then they get on a train and they cross the United States and they arrive in the American capital. And they're told about George Washington, first American president, and they're completely bewildered that the heirs of Washington are not in power. So in Japan, obviously, the descendants of Tokugawa are still in power. So why aren't the heirs of George Washington? Why aren't they president?
别给我们发关于威斯康星切达干酪的信息，因为你几乎买不到那种。一个持久的谜团，武士们也对此感到困惑。然后他们坐上火车横穿美国，抵达了美国首都。他们被告知乔治·华盛顿，第一任美国总统，他们完全困惑为什么华盛顿的后代没有掌权。在日本，显然，德川的后代仍然掌权。那么为什么乔治·华盛顿的后代不是总统呢？
And as for the U.S. Army, the samurai bewildered because the U.S. Army recruits people, so people in America are hired not born to fight. And this seems to the samurai very, very poor, very, very shameful. But of course, the attitudes that the samurai have, these medieval attitudes, you want to frame it like that, the 19th century is coming very, very hard for them. So in the early 1860s, the Shogunate tries to fight back. They try and assert their dignity in the face of the American intrusion. I suppose a bit like the Aztecs or the Ingers trying to assert their dignity in the face of the Spanish.
至于美国军队，武士们感到困惑，因为美国军队招募人员，所以在美国人们是被雇佣而不是天生为了战斗。这对武士来说显得非常非常糟糕，非常非常可耻。但当然，武士所持有的态度，这些中世纪的态度，如果你想这样定义的话，19世纪对他们来说来得非常非常猛烈。所以19世纪60年代初，幕府试图反击。他们试图在面对美国入侵时维护自己的尊严。我想有点像阿兹特克人或印加人试图在面对西班牙人时维护自己的尊严。
And as in South America, in the 16th century, so in Japan in the 19th century, the samurai are repeatedly humiliated. And of course, for a military caste to be publicly humiliated is terrible for its standing and its prestige. So in 1866, samurai from the south of Japan repudiate of the Shogunate, of the Tokugawa clan. And they demand the restoration of full sovereignty to the emperor. They want the emperor to step up to the plate and stop being a kind of cipher. And the following year, the reigning shogun resigns. And then in January 1868, in the imperial palace in Kyoto, the ancient capital, the restoration of rule by the emperor is officially proclaimed. So the house of Tokugawa at last, after 250 years, has fallen. But with the fall
正如16世纪的南美洲一样，19世纪的日本，武士们屡遭羞辱。当然，对于一个军事阶层来说，被公开羞辱对它的地位和声望来说是可怕的。所以1866年，日本南部的武士拒绝了幕府，拒绝了德川氏族。他们要求恢复天皇的全部主权。他们希望天皇站出来，不再做一个傀儡。第二年，在位的将军辞职了。然后在1868年1月，在古都京都的皇宫里，恢复天皇统治的诏书正式颁布。所以德川家族终于在250年后倒台了。但随着
of the Takugawa, you also have the fall of the samurai. So that's the Meiji restoration, isn't it? Which is seen as the sort of the transformative moment in the history of modern Japan, because it's the moment that Japan, you know, it doesn't renounce the past, but it renounces maybe to some degree the cult of the, the stultifying cult of the past and throws itself into the pursuit of modernity. Yeah, so there's a manifesto pledge is proclaimed in the Imperial Palace in April 1868. And it goes, evil customs of the past shall be broken off and everything based.
德川幕府的倒台，你也迎来了武士的倒台。这就是明治维新，不是吗？这被视为现代日本历史上的转型时刻，因为这是日本，你知道，它没有放弃过去，但它在某种程度上放弃了对过去的崇拜，那种令人窒息的对过去的崇拜，并投身于对现代性的追求。是的，1868年4月在皇宫颁布了一份宣言。上面写着，“破除旧有之陋习，一切基于
upon the just laws of nature. And actually, what this means in practice, it is a kind of headlong rush to modernise. And the faster that Japan starts to westernize, obviously the more anachronistic, this kind of hereditary cast of warriors comes to seem. And of course, Japan modernises incredibly effectively. I mean, more effectively probably than any other country that comes into contact with the industrial West. And by the end of 1876, pretty much everything that had made.
自然的公正法则。”实际上，这意味着一种向现代化的全速冲刺。日本开始西化的速度越快，这种世袭的战士阶层就越显得不合时宜。当然，日本现代化的效率非常高。我的意思是，可能比任何其他与工业化西方接触的国家都要有效。到1876年底，几乎所有使
the samurai distinctive for centuries and centuries and centuries has gone. So their elevated kind of position in a formal hierarchy, you know, they're standing as the top cast is abolished, the stipends they'd been receiving from the government, that they've gone, their monopoly on military service, that's gone. Anyone now can join the armed services. The right to wear a sword in public, the katana, that's gone as well. And even their distinctive hairstyle, which anyone who has seen Shogun will immediately recognize, kind of the shaved front with a top knot, that's gone as well. So it's not just the Tokugawa Shogunate that's been abolished, so too has this entire tradition of military rule in Japan that, as we will find out,
武士几个世纪以来与众不同的东西都消失了。所以他们在正式等级制度中的崇高地位，你知道，他们作为最高阶层的地位被废除了，他们从政府那里领取的俸禄，那些消失了，他们对军事服务的垄断，那也消失了。现在任何人都可以加入武装部队。在公共场合佩戴刀剑（武士刀）的权利也消失了。甚至他们独特的发型，任何看过《幕府将军》的人都会立刻认出来，那种剃掉前额留着发髻的发型，也消失了。所以不仅德川幕府被废除了，整个日本的军事统治传统也随之消失了，正如我们将要发现的那样，
stretches way, way, way back into the Middle Ages. I mean, obviously there are people in Japan who are very sad, I suppose, who mourn the death of tradition that comes with the Meiji Restoration. And oddly, Westerners have very ambiguous Satitude too, because on the one hand, people who like Japanese culture love it as a kind of crucible of modernity. But we are constantly fascinated by the sort of the tradition and the reverence for the past and all of that kind of thing, which is why when you go to Japan, as I mean, we've both done, you know, the samurai are everywhere. Katanas are everywhere. I mean, I have to say Sambra Jr. returned with an excellent sword and all kinds of samurai gear from Japan.
一直追溯到中世纪。我的意思是，显然日本有些人非常悲伤，我想，他们哀悼明治维新带来的传统的死亡。奇怪的是，西方人也有非常矛盾的态度，因为一方面，喜欢日本文化的人喜欢它作为现代性的熔炉。但我们一直被那种传统和对过去的敬畏所吸引，这就是为什么当你去日本时，就像我们俩都做过的那样，你知道，武士无处不在。武士刀无处不在。我必须说，小桑布拉从日本带回了一把极好的剑和各种武士装备。
There are definitely people in the West who mourn the collapse of the samurai, even though, of course, you know, it's the West that has precipitated their downfall. And I think what they particularly admire and regret is a kind of aesthetic. It's the look that the samurai have. And so, for instance, you know, these suits of armour that will be familiar in the West that you get in museums, say British Museum or wherever, these are sold by ex-Samurai because every samurai had to have a suit of armour. They don't need them anymore. They're a bit short of money. Now they're not getting their stipends. So they flog them off.
西方确实有人哀悼武士的崩溃，尽管当然，你知道，正是西方加速了他们的灭亡。我认为他们特别钦佩和遗憾的是一种审美。这就是武士的样子。所以，例如，你知道，这些在西方博物馆（比如大英博物馆或其他地方）里常见的盔甲，这些都是前武士卖掉的，因为每个武士都必须有一套盔甲。他们不再需要它们了。他们有点缺钱。现在他们领不到俸禄了。所以他们把它们卖掉。
And so they go around the world and they kind of broadcast the look of the samurai across the west. And helmets in particular become kind of icons of what in France is known as a Japanese. It's kind of the craze for Japanese art, Japanese fashion, Japanese vibes that completely sweeps Western Europe in the 19th century. And they remain absolutely iconic to this day. and their instant signifiers of medieval Japan, even though often, of course, they come from the 16th or 17th centuries. And you talked about a very, very celebrated marker of that influence,
于是它们流向世界各地，并在西方传播了武士的形象。头盔尤其成为了法国所称的“日本主义”（Japonisme）的标志。这是一种在19世纪席卷西欧的对日本艺术、日本时尚、日本氛围的狂热。直到今天，它们仍然是绝对的标志性符号，是中世纪日本的即时象征，尽管当然，它们往往来自16或17世纪。你谈到了那种影响的一个非常、非常著名的标志，
which endures into the present day. And it's there in the British Museum show, because you begin with this stunning suit of armour, which I described. You go around the show, and then at the end, you have an outfit that deliberately echoed the suit of armour that you got at the beginning, And this is the costume worn by Darth Vader. And George Lucas's suggestion to the costume designer when, you know, they were prepping for Star Wars, he said, like what's some kind of big helmet like a Japanese warrior. And it's not a precise instruction, but everyone immediately, you know, you immediately know what that signifies. The designer obviously knew. And that's partly because Star Wars is based on Kurosawa films.
它一直延续到今天。在大英博物馆的展览中就有体现，因为你从我描述的那套令人惊叹的盔甲开始。你参观完展览，最后你会看到一套故意呼应你开头看到的那套盔甲的服装，这就是达斯·维达穿的戏服。当乔治·卢卡斯为《星球大战》做准备时，他对服装设计师建议说，像日本武士那样做一个大头盔。这不是一个精确的指令，但每个人立刻，你知道，你立刻就知道那象征着什么。设计师显然知道。这部分是因为《星球大战》是基于黑泽明的电影。
The Kurosara films are their model for Star Wars in some ways. The Hidden Fortress, I believe. Yes, absolutely, because it's not just the look of the samurai that people feel in the West feel that they know. It's also something more than that. It's this idea of there being a code of the samurai, which, you know, in Star Wars becomes the kind of the Jedi and all that kind of stuff. And this code is, it's given the name of Bushido, Bushi is warrior, so the way of the warrior. And I had always assumed, I would imagine that most people listening to this show would assume, assume that this was a kind of authentic code going right the way back to the beginnings of the samurai.
黑泽明的电影在某些方面是《星球大战》的模型。《战国英豪》，我相信。是的，绝对是，因为不仅仅是西方人觉得他们了解的武士形象。还有比这更多的东西。这就是武士道（Bushido）的概念，（Bushi是战士，所以是战士之道）。我一直以为，我想听这个节目的大多数人也会认为，这是一个一直追溯到武士起源的真实准则。
So it's there in Ghost of Sashima, for instance. This is the way of the samurai. And obviously it's there in Star Wars. So Yoda is very Boshito, this great teacher passing on the way of the warrior. And George Lucas, when he was picking up on this idea of Boshito as a kind of model for the Jedi in Star Wars, he was part of a kind of a continual. and which reached back decades. So in 1908, this is what Baden Powell, the founder of the boy scouts had to say about Boshido.
所以它存在于《对马岛之魂》中，例如。这就是武士之道。显然它存在于《星球大战》中。所以尤达非常“武士道”，这位伟大的导师传承着战士之道。乔治·卢卡斯在将“武士道”作为《星球大战》中绝地武士模型时，他是一个连续体的一部分，
He's writing in scouting for boys. The Japanese have their Boshido or laws of the old samurai warriors, just as we have chivalry or rules of the knights of the Middle Ages. And Baden Powell is not wrong to recognize something of chivalry, you know, the medieval code from Latin Christendom. Shido, because actually that was one of the ingredients of Shito, because actually, far from drawing on a moral code that reached back to the Middle Ages, Bishido was pretty much a modern invention, a post-Miji restoration invention.
这个连续体可以追溯到几十年前。1908年，童子军创始人贝登堡对武士道是这样说的。他在《童子军手册》中写道：“日本人有他们的武士道或古老武士的法则，就像我们有中世纪骑士的骑士精神或规则一样。”贝登堡并没有错，他认识到了骑士精神（来自拉丁基督教世界的中世纪准则）的一些东西。武士道，因为实际上那是武士道的成分之一，因为实际上，武士道远非借鉴了追溯到中世纪的道德准则，它几乎是一个现代发明，一个明治维新后的发明。
And it was a fusion of authentic Japanese traditions that was seasoned by admiration. I'm very proud to say for the model of the English gentleman. So there's a little bit of the English gentleman in Boshito and also the chivalric traditions of Europe because the Japanese looked at these traditions and said, oh, we'll feed them in and try and make something that's simultaneously Japanese and Western. So you're saying the cult of the samurai is, and to some extent, a modern invention informed by English gentlemen of the late 19th century. That would be immensely pleasing if it were true.
它是真实日本传统的融合，并因对英国绅士模范的钦佩而增色。我很自豪地说，武士道里有一点英国绅士的影子，还有欧洲的骑士传统，因为日本人审视了这些传统并说，哦，我们将把它们融入其中，并尝试创造出一种既是日本的又是西方的东西。所以你是说武士崇拜在某种程度上是受19世纪末英国绅士影响的现代发明。如果这是真的，那将是非常令人愉快的。
Yes. Obviously most of it comes from authentic Japanese traditions, but there is a seasoning of the English gentlemen, and there is definitely a touch of the kind of the medieval night. And it kind of bubbles up in the late 19th century, into the 20th century. And then in the 20th century, it becomes one of the great cultural influences, of course, on Japanese culture, but also on global culture. So in the early decades of the 20th century, it's appropriated by the Japanese military and perverted to their own uses. And it takes Japan to some really very dark places because Boshito becomes a kind of ideological justification for what the Japanese army is doing in Korea, in China,
是的。显然大部分来自真实的日本传统，但确实有英国绅士的调味，而且绝对有一点中世纪骑士的味道。它在19世纪末到20世纪冒了出来。然后在20世纪，它成为了对日本文化，也对全球文化的最伟大的文化影响之一。所以20世纪初，它被日本军方挪用并歪曲为自己的用途。它把日本带向了一些非常黑暗的地方，因为武士道成为了日本军队在朝鲜、在中国、
in the Second World War. And when the Americans occupy Japan, they feel that much of what Japan had done, the war crimes and so on, is to be blamed on this notion of Bishida, which they see as a kind of ancient expression of Japanese militarism. And so they ban it and they come down hard on cultural representations of samurai. And when the American occupation ends, the Japanese are ready to kind of reappropriate this tradition. So the ideal of Meshido, as it turns out, you know, it has been perfect for Japanese military before the war, and it proves perfect for the Japanese entertainment industry
在第二次世界大战中所作所为的一种意识形态辩护。当美国人占领日本时，他们觉得日本所做的大部分事情，战争罪行等等，都应该归咎于这种“武士道”观念，他们将其视为日本军国主义的一种古老表现。所以他们禁止了它，并严厉打击了武士的文化表现。当美国占领结束时，日本人准备重新挪用这一传统。所以“武士道”的理想，事实证明，你知道，它在战前对日本军方来说是完美的，而它在战后对日本娱乐业来说也证明是完美的。
after the war. So it helps the samurai to become kind of, you know, a great theme in Japanese film, TV, manga, and sometimes the samurai are portrayed as kind of role models, models of courage and loyalty and honour, and the code of the samurai is taken seriously. But sometimes they are more morally complex, more ambivalent figures. And this also has become part of what has made the samurai Japan's great cultural export throughout the 20th century and into the 21st century. So, you know, we've talked about how it's there in Ghost of Sashima and Star Wars, but it's also the morally ambivalent model of the samurai is there in spaghetti westerns. It's there in the films of Quentin Tarantino. You know, he loves a katana. Yeah. And people who are interested in this, we will be exploring it further. We'll be looking at Star Wars, spaghetti westerns and so on, in a special bonus with Oleg Benesh, who wrote a fabulous book, inventing the way of the samurai, which very much does what it says on the tin. It's kind of the the definitive study of Meshido as an invented tradition.
所以它帮助武士成为了日本电影、电视、漫画中的一个伟大主题，有时武士被描绘成某种榜样，勇气、忠诚和荣誉的典范，武士的准则被认真对待。但有时他们是更复杂的道德、更矛盾的人物。这也成为了使武士成为日本在整个20世纪和21世纪最伟大的文化出口产品的一部分。所以，你知道，我们谈到了它在《对马岛之魂》和《星球大战》中是如何存在的，但这种道德矛盾的武士模型也存在于意大利西部片中。它存在于昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的电影中。你知道，他热爱武士刀。是的。对这些感兴趣的人，我们将进一步探讨。我们将看看《星球大战》、意大利西部片等等，在与奥列格·贝内什的特别节目中，他写了一本精彩的书《发明武士之道》，这本书名副其实。它是关于作为一种发明传统的武士道的权威研究。
But just because samurai are mythologised, just because they feature in all kinds of popular culture and one, it doesn't mean there's not a historical reality behind it. And let's get back to the historical reality. So they definitely are samurai in the distant medieval past, and they do endure for hundreds of years, and they do have amazing armour and swords, and they've got their traditions and they've got their code and all that, right? There isn't a code of the samurai, which is kind of followed for centuries and centuries and centuries, but they do have moral codes, they do have traditions, they do act in
但仅仅因为武士被神话，仅仅因为他们出现在各种流行文化中，并不意味着背后没有历史现实。让我们回到历史现实。所以他们确实是遥远中世纪过去的武士，他们确实持续了数百年，他们确实有惊人的盔甲和刀剑，他们有他们的传统，他们有他们的准则，等等，对吧？并没有一种被延续了几个世纪的“武士准则”，但他们确实有道德准则，他们确实有传统，他们确实在
obedience to very demanding ideals of shame and honour. And I think above all, and maybe this is, you know, the key to understanding why they have been figures of such enduring glamour for so long throughout Japanese history and then more recently into global history is the fact that Right from the very beginning, the samurai were masterly at the art of creating their own myths. And this was a very urgent task for them. And this is because, unlike, say, in the Frankish worlds in medieval Europe or the Viking worlds, warriors in medieval Japan initially did not stand at the apex of society. They are outsiders. They're out in the provinces, in the wilds. And the aristocrats who are at the centre in the imperial court look down on them. They regard them with contempt. And the word for warrior bushy, you know, it's a bit of a dirty word. And the word samurai is even more so. It's even more low rent. Because literally, a samurai does not mean a warrior. It means a vassal, a subordinate, a person who is in service.
服从非常苛刻的羞耻和荣誉理想。我认为最重要的是，也许这就是理解为什么他们在整个日本历史以及后来进入全球历史中长期以来一直具有如此持久魅力的关键，那就是从一开始，武士就非常擅长创造自己的神话。这是一项对他们来说非常紧迫的任务。这是因为，与中世纪欧洲的法兰克世界或维京世界不同，中世纪日本的战士最初并不处于社会顶端。他们是局外人。他们在省份，在荒野中。而处于帝国宫廷中心的贵族看不起他们。他们以蔑视的态度对待他们。而“武士”（Bushi）这个词，你知道，有点脏。而“武士”（Samurai）这个词更是如此。它更低级。因为字面上，“武士”并不意味着战士。它意味着家臣、下属、一个处于服务地位的人。
to a great lord. And so it's not enough for the samurai. We're talking about the rise of the samurai. They're upwardly mobile. That's not enough because they are parvenus. And like parvenus throughout history, they have to cope with the snobbery of those whom they are displacing. And so they can do this partly by kind of affecting the manners of the court, by behaving as courtiers do. But I think it's more satisfying for all them in the long run to start establishing their own standards, their own morals, their own myths. And so this over the course of the Middle Ages is what they came to do. And it's these myths which do originate in the Middle Ages, which touch the samurai class with this incredible glamour, which is there to the present day and which it fascinates people
侍奉一位伟大的领主。所以这对武士来说是不够的。我们谈论的是武士的崛起。他们是向上流动的。这还不够，因为他们是暴发户。像历史上所有的暴发户一样，他们必须应对那些被他们取代的人的势利。所以他们可以通过某种方式影响宫廷礼仪，通过像朝臣那样行事来做到这一点。但我认为从长远来看，开始建立他们自己的标准、他们自己的道德、他们自己的神话对他们来说更令人满意。所以这在中世纪的过程中就是他们所做的事情。正是这些起源于中世纪的神话，赋予了武士阶层这种令人难以置信的魅力，这种魅力一直持续到今天，并吸引着人们。
in the West as much as in Japan. And so to trace the the way in which this myth evolves, you know, we need to go back and look at the kind of the reality right at the beginning and ask, you know, who are the first samurai? How on earth had the Japanese court managed to survive for so long without having a cast of warriors? I mean, it's very unusual kind of, you know, if you think about Europe in the Middle Ages. It's odd for us, I think, to imagine that the ruling class weren't warriors at all, despised warriors. And then what happens to make that change, how is it that the court collapses and this class of warriors emerges? Right. So we should be asking and answering those questions and we should be heading to Kyoto
在西方和日本一样。因此，为了追溯这一神话演变的方式，我们需要回到最初的现实，问问自己：谁是第一批武士？日本朝廷究竟是如何在没有武士阶层的情况下维持了那么长时间的统治？我的意思是，如果你想想中世纪的欧洲，这真的很不寻常。我认为，对于我们来说，想象统治阶级根本不是武士，甚至鄙视武士，是很奇怪的。那么，后来发生了什么导致了这种变化？朝廷是如何崩溃的，而这个武士阶层又是如何崛起的？没错。所以我们应该提出并回答这些问题，我们应该前往京都。
in the year 940 and we'll be kicking off with the display of a particularly gruesome and implausibly talkative trophy. And we'll be doing all that after the break. Where are my gloves? Come on, heat. any day now. Winter is hard, but your groceries don't have to be. This winter, stay warm. Tap the banner to order your groceries online at voila.ca. Enjoy in-store prices without leaving your home.
在公元940年，我们将从展示一个特别可怕且不可思议地健谈的战利品开始。我们将在休息后完成所有这些。我的手套在哪里？来吧，暖气。随时都行。冬天很艰难，但你的杂货不必如此。这个冬天，保持温暖。点击横幅在voila.ca在线订购杂货。足不出户即可享受店内价格。
You'll find the same regular prices online as in-store. Many promotions are available both in-store and online, though some may vary. When Westcham first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was peak fashion, in-line skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel. While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board.
你会发现网上的常规价格与店内相同。许多促销活动在店内和网上都有，尽管有些可能会有所不同。当WestJet在1996年首次起飞时，氛围有点不同。人们认为牛仔配牛仔是时尚巅峰，轮滑鞋随处可见，每三个女性中就有两个留着“瑞秋头”。虽然这些东西留在了90年代，但有一件事没有变，那就是当你登上WestJet飞机时感受到的那种温暖的感觉。
Here's to WestJetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. Okay, when I sell my business, I want the best tax and investment advice. I want to help my kids, and I want to give back to the community.
为自96年以来的WestJet干杯。与我们一起穿越时空，并真正与我们一起旅行，访问westjet.com斜杠30年。好的，当我卖掉我的生意时，我想要最好的税务和投资建议。我想帮助我的孩子们，我想回馈社区。
Ooh, then it's the vacation of a lifetime. I wonder if my first. my out of office has a forever setter. An IG Private Wealth Advisor creates the clarity you need with plans that harmonize your business, your family, and your dreams. Get financial advice that puts you at the center. Find your advisor at IGPrivatewealth.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
哦，那将是一生难忘的假期。我想知道我的“外出办公”自动回复是否设置了永久生效。IG私人财富顾问通过协调你的事业、家庭和梦想的计划，为你创造所需的清晰度。获取以你为中心的财务建议。在IGPrivatewealth.com找到你的顾问。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。
We are at the beginning of April 940, and we're in the imperial capital of Japan. Hean Kyo, the city of peace and tranquility, known today as Kyoto. And a load of horsemen have just ridden from Kanto, which is the great plain, in which Tokyo, modern-day Tokyo stands. They have crossed the mountains, and they have brought with them a gift for the emperor. Tom, what's the gift? Well, the gift is the severed head of the most notorious warlord in Japan. And this warlord is called Taira no Massacado. And he is a remarkable man of whom remarkable things are reported. So first of all, he's an absolute unit. He is seven foot tall and the Japanese are not at all people. So he really stands out. In his left eye,
现在是940年4月初，我们身处日本的皇都。平安京，和平与安宁之城，即今天的京都。一群骑兵刚刚从关东骑马赶来，关东就是东京，即现代东京所在的平原。他们翻山越岭，为天皇带来了一份礼物。汤姆，这份礼物是什么？嗯，这份礼物是日本最臭名昭著的军阀的首级。这位军阀名叫平将门。他是一个非凡的人，关于他有许多非凡的传闻。首先，他是一个绝对的巨人。他身高七英尺，而日本人根本不是高个子民族。所以他真的很显眼。在他的左眼里，
he has two pupils, which again, unusual. That is unusual. Indeed, unheard of. But perhaps the most striking thing about him is he is completely invulnerable to weapons. And this is thanks to his mother, who was a giant snake, and I gather it's the custom for giant snakes to lick their offspring. And so his mother, the giant snake, had licked Massacardo all over, with the exception of his forehead, and her saliva had the magical power of making him invulnerable to weapons. So there's a slight hint there of Achilles. Two pupils, that's weird. Anyway, what happens to the head? What do they do with it? So the head is exhibited in the marketplace of Kyoto. So they, they, they, There's a spike.
他有两个瞳孔，这也很不寻常。那确实不寻常。确实，闻所未闻。但关于他最引人注目的或许是他对武器完全免疫。这要归功于他的母亲，她是一条巨蛇，我了解到巨蛇有舔舐后代的习俗。所以他的母亲，那条巨蛇，把平将门全身都舔了一遍，除了他的前额，而她的唾液具有使他刀枪不入的魔力。所以这里有一点阿喀琉斯的影子。两个瞳孔，这很奇怪。总之，那个头颅后来怎么样了？他们拿它怎么办？所以这个头颅被陈列在京都的市场上。所以他们，他们，他们，有一个长矛。
They put the head on the spike and they lift the pole up so that the head is gazing out over the marketplace. And the moment the pole has been levered into position, the eyes open, complete with the left eye with its two pupils. And they glare around angrily and the head demands to know where the rest of the body is. So very annoyed that the body parts have gone missing. And it stays there for several months and all this time it doesn't rot in the slightest. It's silent for periods.
他们把头颅插在长矛上，把杆子竖起来，让头颅俯瞰着市场。就在杆子被固定好的那一刻，眼睛睁开了，包括那只带有两个瞳孔的左眼。它们愤怒地四处瞪视，头颅要求知道身体的其他部分在哪里。所以它对身体部位的丢失感到非常恼火。它在那里待了几个月，在这期间它一点也没有腐烂。它有时保持沉默，
and then it has another massive rant demanding its, you know, its legs back and its arms and so on. And then after several months, it suddenly starts to glow and then it shoots up off the spike and it goes bombing off across Kyoto in search of its decapitated corpse. And it heads eastwards across this great mountain range, which separates Kyoto from Canto, which is the great plain to the east. And as it's flying over Canto, this head is brought. down, either because it gets shot down by a god, that's according to one account, or because it crash lands for reasons that aren't explained. But whatever, the head crash lands and
然后它又会进行另一次大规模的咆哮，要求找回它的腿、手臂等等。几个月后，它突然开始发光，然后从长矛上射出，在京都上空横冲直撞，寻找它被斩首的尸体。它向东穿过将京都与关东（东部大平原）隔开的巨大山脉。当它飞过关东时，这个头颅被击落了，要么是因为它被一位神射落，这是根据一种说法，要么是因为它因无法解释的原因坠毁了。但无论如何，头颅坠毁了，
locals go and pick it up and they wash it and they bury it and they raise a mound over it. And of course, this is regarded as a very sacred place. And people go to Tokyo today, you can still see it, this mound, the tomb of Masgado's head. Because it stands right in the middle of Tokyo's business district, you know, I mean, among the most valuable real estate in the entire world. So you would think, well, surely this has been clear, surely they've built some skyscraper or something. But they haven't because every attempt to build on it has resulted in disaster. So, you know, they might lift up a crane and the crane comes crashing down or the head of the company that is trying to develop it, kind of gets run over by a car or something.
当地人去捡起它，清洗它，埋葬它，并在上面堆起了一个土丘。当然，这被视为一个非常神圣的地方。人们今天去东京，仍然可以看到它，这个土丘，平将门的头颅之墓。因为它就矗立在东京商业区的中心，你知道，我的意思是，在全世界最昂贵的房地产之中。所以你会想，好吧，肯定已经被清理了吧，肯定他们已经盖了什么摩天大楼之类的。但他们没有，因为每一次试图在上面建造的尝试都导致了灾难。所以，你知道，他们可能会吊起一台起重机，起重机就轰然倒塌，或者试图开发它的公司老板被车撞了之类的。
And so the Japanese in Tokyo have drawn the lesson that you shouldn't try and errone. raise the last resting place of Massacardo's head. And so his tomb stands there to this day. This is because he's the first samurai, right? So you can't mess with the first samurai. And he's the guy who, he's the founding father of this tradition that we're talking about in this series. Correct. So Massacardo is essentially, he's kind of fated as the first samurai. And that is absolutely why he, you know, why he has this kind of resonance, this mythic status. So obviously, there's quite a lot to unpick here. So again, because geography is, is really important in this story. Let's just look at how the geography of Japan maps onto the
所以东京的日本人得出的教训是，你不应该试图去打扰平将门头颅的最后安息之地。所以他的坟墓至今仍在那里。这是因为他是第一位武士，对吧？所以你不能招惹第一位武士。他是我们在本系列中讨论的这一传统的开创者。没错。所以平将门本质上被视为第一位武士。这绝对是他为什么拥有这种共鸣、这种神话地位的原因。显然，这里有很多东西需要梳理。所以，再次强调，因为地理在这个故事中非常重要，让我们看看日本的地理是如何映射到
kind of the politics of the empire in the mid-10th century, because this is essentially what the story is illustrating, the political geography of Japan. So Massacardo's head has been brought from the plain of canto, which literally means east of the mountain range, east of the barrier. And it's been brought to Kyoto because Kyoto is, it's not just the great center of power, it's the only center of power in the Japanese archipelago in this period. And it's been founded in 794. It's the seat of the Japanese emperor. And the emperor rules as a lineal descendant of the sun goddess.
10世纪中叶帝国的政治格局上的，因为这本质上就是这个故事所展示的内容，即日本的政治地理。所以平将门的头颅是从关东平原带来的，关东字面意思就是山脉以东，关隘以东。它被带到京都，因为京都不仅是伟大的权力中心，而且是这一时期日本群岛唯一的权力中心。它始建于794年。它是日本天皇的驻地。天皇作为太阳女神的直系后裔进行统治。
And then a succession of 15 emperors who between them were supposed to have ruled for centuries and centuries and centuries. So they're a bit like the kind of the biblical prophets. They have improbable lifespans. So that's the story that's told. The reality is rather different. What becomes the Japanese imperial dynasty had originally been just one of a number of competing kind of aristocratic families. And it's only at the end of the 7th century that it succeeds in establishing its overall supremacy and with it its imperial status.
然后是一连串的15位天皇，他们加起来据说统治了几个世纪又几个世纪。所以他们有点像圣经里的先知。他们有着不可思议的寿命。这就是流传的故事。现实却大不相同。后来成为日本皇室的家族最初只是众多相互竞争的贵族家庭之一。直到7世纪末，它才成功确立了其整体霸权，并随之确立了其皇室地位。
And then having established the supremacy, of course, it faces the challenge of maintaining it. How are they going to do that? And initially, they do this in a kind of classic way by establishing a monopoly of violence. That's what imperial regimes invariably do. So the emperor requires all the other lords to hand over their military equipment, their crossbows and so on. And these are confiscated and put in regional depots that are dotted around the empire, so that they can be drawn on in case of emergency.
在确立了霸权之后，它当然面临着维持霸权的挑战。他们将如何做到这一点？最初，他们以一种经典的方式做到这一点，即建立暴力垄断。这是帝国政权总是会做的事情。所以天皇要求所有其他领主交出他们的军事装备，他们的弩等等。这些被没收并存放在散布在帝国各地的区域仓库中，以便在紧急情况下可以调用。
See, this is a period when the Japanese are sedulously imitating China, which is the great model for them. And in China, the army consists of a great mass of conscripted peasants. And so the Japanese emperor does the same. This is going to provide him with his manpower. But it doesn't really work in the Japanese context. And that's partly because there are far fewer peasants in Japan than there are in China. So peasants don't really provide the emperor with the kind of.
看，这是一个日本人勤奋模仿中国的时期，中国是他们的伟大榜样。在中国，军队由大量征召的农民组成。所以日本天皇也做了同样的事情。这将为他提供人力。但在日本的背景下，这并不奏效。部分原因是日本的农民远少于中国。所以农民并没有真正为天皇提供他所需要的
military mass that he needs. It's also because there is a massive fiscal crisis and it becomes too expensive for the emperor to run his own army. And also peasants just make terrible soldiers, they're hopeless. They're always kind of running away and stuff. But just what do they need the soldiers for? Because who are they fighting? They're not going to be attacked by external enemies. Are they China, Korea or whoever? So what do they, is it internal threats? By this point, the southwestern half of Japan has basically been pacif. So that would include Kushu, which is the kind of southwestern island, and then you have the main island, Honshu, up to this kind of great range of mountains east of Kyoto.
军事力量。这也是因为存在严重的财政危机，天皇运营自己的军队变得太昂贵了。而且农民也是糟糕的士兵，他们毫无用处。他们总是逃跑之类的。但他们到底需要士兵做什么呢？因为他们在和谁打仗？他们不会受到外部敌人的攻击。是吗？中国、韩国或其他什么人？所以他们，这是内部威胁吗？到这个时候，日本的西南部基本上已经被平定了。这包括九州，即西南部岛屿，然后是主岛本州，一直到京都以东的这片大山脉。
All of these have been pacified. And so you don't really need an army in that kind of southwestern half of Japan, because effectively it's fine to have civilian government there. And all the regional aristocracy by now are obsessed by hanging out in Kyoto in this great capital. And they go there and they kind of write poetry and they practice calligraphy and they mix incense. And this is how you prove your status, not by going out and fighting. And actually, it's quite like Versailles in the 18th century. Lords do not want to stay in the provinces.
所有这些都已被平定。所以你真的不需要在日本的西南部拥有军队，因为实际上那里有文官政府就足够了。而所有的区域贵族现在都沉迷于在京都这个伟大的首都里消磨时光。他们去那里写诗、练习书法、调配香料。这就是你证明自己地位的方式，而不是通过出去打仗。实际上，这很像18世纪的凡尔赛宫。领主们不想待在省份里。
They want to go to the court. They want to show off there. They want to adopt the arts of peace. And so warriors, you know, as the centuries pass, come to seem to the court. You know, they're uncouth. They're murderous. They're basically they're scum. They're kind of literally described as dogs. War has become something that is vulgar. It's become something declassé. It's something that no one with any standing or status would dream of doing.
他们想去朝廷。他们想在那里炫耀。他们想采用和平的艺术。所以武士，你知道，随着世纪的流逝，在朝廷看来，他们是粗鲁的。他们是嗜杀的。他们基本上是人渣。他们甚至被描述为狗。战争已经成为一种粗俗的事情。它已经成为一种降格的事情。这是任何有地位或身份的人都不会梦想去做的事情。
And yet, you might say that any regime that has a contempt or disregard for military muscle is living on borrowed time because that's what power is all about. So presumably they don't ignore military muscle completely. Well, no, because we've said the northeastern reaches of Honshu, this main island of Japan, That remains un-pacified. And so the provinces beyond the mountains east of Kyoto have this kind of real marcher feel. You know, they are kind of frontier zone. And here, the imperial government has no option but to reverse its previous policy and to encourage the governors, the lords, who live in these northeastern provinces to levy their own troops because they need them to keep order there. And so who are these troops? Well, these lords,
然而，你可能会说，任何蔑视或忽视军事力量的政权都是在借来的时间里生活，因为这就是权力的全部意义所在。所以大概他们并没有完全忽视军事力量。嗯，没有，因为我们说过本州（日本主岛）的东北部地区，那仍然没有被平定。所以京都以东山脉之外的省份有一种真正的边疆感。你知道，它们是某种前沿地带。在这里，帝国政府别无选择，只能扭转其先前的政策，鼓励居住在这些东北省份的总督和领主征召他们自己的军队，因为他们需要这些军队在那里维持秩序。那么这些军队是谁呢？嗯，这些领主，
These lords are still kind of emulating the Chinese model and recruiting peasants who serve them as infantry, but there's the same problem. The peasants are rubbish. They're always running away and throwing away their weapons and things. And so the key figures, the key players, as in medieval Europe, are horsemen. And these are called Suamono. And these are warriors who are trained from childhood to shoot arrows from the saddle. So in that sense, they are like the kind of the classical horsemen of the steps, you know, the Mongols included. And the great obsession of these horsemen in northeastern Japan is honour and the great fear is disgrace, which isn't to say that they're not also very, very obsessed by financial rewards and other rewards as well, because they are.
这些领主仍然在模仿中国的模式，招募农民作为步兵为他们服务，但存在同样的问题。农民是垃圾。他们总是逃跑，扔掉武器之类的。所以关键人物，关键参与者，就像中世纪的欧洲一样，是骑兵。这些被称为“武士”。这些是从童年起就受过训练，可以在马背上射箭的战士。从这个意义上说，他们就像草原上的古典骑兵，你知道，包括蒙古人在内。这些日本东北部骑兵的巨大执念是荣誉，而巨大的恐惧是耻辱，这并不是说他们不也非常、非常执着于经济奖励和其他奖励，因为他们确实如此。
And it's this kind of fusion of obsessional interest in their own honour and an obsessional interest from getting on in life that makes them, you know, if you want a samurai code, that is the samurai code. They are called samurai because they are the retainers who are recruited by the local lords to serve him as his muscle, you know, as his kind of backup. You might say, so as a layman, I might say that's very risky because basically if local magnates are recruiting their own troops to fight off, you know, the barbarians or whatever, then, you know, the lesson of late Roman history is when there are, you know, there won't be long before one of them declares himself emperor and marches on the capital. No? In the long run, as we will see, you are not wrong. And this
正是这种对自身荣誉的执着兴趣和对在生活中取得成功的执着兴趣的融合，使他们，如果你想要一个武士准则，那就是武士准则。他们被称为武士，因为他们是当地领主招募的随从，作为他的武力，你知道，作为他的后盾。你可能会说，作为一个外行，我可能会说这风险很大，因为基本上如果地方豪强招募自己的军队来抵御，你知道，野蛮人什么的，那么，你知道，罗马帝国晚期的教训是，当有，你知道，用不了多久就会有人宣布自己为皇帝并向首都进军。不是吗？从长远来看，正如我们将看到的，你并没有错。而这
is obviously going to be a problem, but not immediately. And this is for various reasons. And the first is that these provincial governors to the northeast of the great mountain rage that separates Kyoto from the northeast of Honshu, they all hate each other. Right. So it's very, very unlikely that they're going to gang up and kind of march on Kyoto. And if there is a rebellion, then it's very easy for the imperial government to find someone on the scene who's going to crush it. Because Kyoto is the source of all patronage. And so all you have to do is say, I'll send you a nice calligraphy kit, go and beat up this
显然会成为一个问题，但不是立即。这是由于各种原因。首先是这些位于将京都与本州东北部隔开的巨大山脉东北部的省长们，他们都互相憎恨。没错。所以他们联合起来向京都进军的可能性非常小。如果发生叛乱，帝国政府很容易在现场找到人来镇压它。因为京都是一切恩惠的来源。所以你所要做的就是说，我会送你一套精美的书法工具，去打败这个
guy and the guy, you know, he'll do it. And again, there's this whole Versailles thing. Because even provincial governors out in the sticks, you know, they buy into the notion of what is fashionable, of what gives them status, which is the kind of the ideals of a centralized court running everything. And Kyoto provides the only standard by which even people out in, you know, the northeast of Honshu want to be judged. And it's the only source of the lifestyle that ultimately matters, the lifestyle that gives you status. And Carl Friday, great scholar of early medieval Japan. He compares these governors, these warlords in the northeast of Honshu
家伙，那个人，你知道，他会做的。同样，这里也有凡尔赛的那一套。因为即使是偏远地区的省长，你知道，他们也认同什么是时尚，什么是给他们地位的东西，那就是由一个中央集权的朝廷管理一切的理想。京都提供了唯一的标准，即使是身处本州东北部的人也想以此来衡量自己。它是唯一能带来最终重要的生活方式的来源，那种赋予你地位的生活方式。卡尔·弗莱，早期中世纪日本的伟大学者。他将这些东北部的总督、军阀
with CEOs today, and so to quote Friday, who tend to identify more closely with CEOs in other lines of business than with the workers, engineers or middle managers in their own. So it's like, you know, tech CEOs, industrial CEOs, financial CEOs, going to Davos, they have more in common with each other than they do with the kind of the minions far below them in their kind of various corporate structures. So in other words, you know, in the Japanese context, just because you employ mercenaries doesn't mean that you want to be mercenary yourself. You know, you want to keep them at a kind of distance. And they are related to the emperors by an arch, aren't they? They're from the imperial family, most of these governors?
与今天的首席执行官进行了比较，引用弗莱的话，他们往往比与自己公司里的工人、工程师或中层管理人员相比，更倾向于认同其他业务领域的首席执行官。所以就像，你知道，科技CEO、工业CEO、金融CEO去达沃斯一样，他们之间的共同点比他们与各自公司结构中远在下方的下属之间的共同点更多。换句话说，你知道，在日本的背景下，仅仅因为你雇佣了雇佣兵并不意味着你自己想成为雇佣兵。你知道，你想把他们保持在一定的距离。而且他们与天皇有亲缘关系，不是吗？这些总督大多数来自皇室？
Yeah, so that's a third factor that is kind of reigning in displays of military brackado, that are not sanctioned by the court. So regular listeners to the rest of history may recall that this is not the first series that we've done on Imperial Japan, because last year we did a couple of episodes on the great female writers at the Imperial Japanese court around the year 1000. And the first of these episodes was on the tale of Genji, which is an enormous 1,100-page novel written around the Year 1000 by Murasaki Shikibu Lady Murasaki and set in the Imperial Court. And the hero of that novel was the son of an emperor by one of his concubines. And because he's the son of a concubine, he has no prospect of inheriting the throne. And so his father, the emperor, is keen for this boy who he recognizes as being very talented to have a career of public service rather than kind of hanging around in the palace being a drone, doing nothing. And so he takes this very drastic step. He removes the boy from the imperial family by giving him.
是的，所以这是抑制未经朝廷批准的军事炫耀的第三个因素。经常收听《历史的其余部分》的听众可能还记得，这不是我们制作的关于帝国日本的第一个系列，因为去年我们制作了几集关于公元1000年左右日本皇室宫廷中伟大的女性作家的节目。这些剧集中的第一集是关于《源氏物语》，这是一部由紫式部（紫夫人）在公元1000年左右撰写的长达1100页的巨著，背景设定在皇宫。这部小说的英雄是天皇与其中一位妃子所生的儿子。因为他是妃子的儿子，他没有继承皇位的希望。所以他的父亲，天皇，热衷于让这个他认为非常有才华的男孩从事公共服务，而不是在宫殿里游手好闲，无所事事。所以他采取了这个非常激烈的步骤。他通过给这个男孩一个
what no emperor ever has, namely a surname. So this young prince is not seen as a, you know, he's not being disgraced. It's not because he's misbehaved. It's actually the opposite. It's because his father recognizes in him great talents and doesn't want them to atrophy, doesn't want them to go to waste. He wants them to, you know, he wants this boy to go out and kind of, you know, make something of his life. And so, as you said, the surname this boy is given is Genji. And as a Genji, he belongs to two realms. He belongs to the realm of his father. the realm of the imperial family, but also the realm of the nobility, of the great kind of public figures who serve the palace. And Lady Mirosaki, when she was writing the tale of Genji
没有天皇拥有过的东西，即姓氏，将他从皇室中除名。所以这个年轻的王子并没有被视为，你知道，他并没有蒙羞。这不是因为他行为不端。实际上恰恰相反。这是因为他的父亲在他身上看到了巨大的才华，不想让它们萎缩，不想让它们浪费。他希望他们，你知道，他希望这个男孩出去，你知道，成就一番事业。所以，正如你所说，这个男孩被赋予的姓氏是源氏。作为源氏，他属于两个领域。他属于他父亲的领域，皇室的领域，但也属于贵族领域，属于服务于宫殿的伟大公众人物的领域。紫夫人，当她在写《源氏物语》时
in the year 1000, was writing it as a historical novel. So she is casting Genji, her hero, as the first prince to be deprinsed, if you like, to lose his kind of princely standing. But as she well knew, Engie was not the only one because this is a process that carries on throughout the 10th century. And this is because emperors in Kyoto have multitudes of wives and concubines. And as a result, they have kind of vast progenies. And even by the 9th century, there are simply too many princes of the imperial system to handle. So even with our own beloved royal family, this is an issue. You accumulate princely clutter.
在公元1000年，她是把它当作历史小说来写的。所以她把源氏，她的英雄，塑造为第一个被“去王子化”的王子，如果你愿意的话，失去了他的王子地位。但正如她所知，源氏并不是唯一的一个，因为这是一个贯穿整个10世纪的过程。这是因为京都的天皇有众多的妻子和妃子。结果，他们有大量的后代。即使到了9世纪，皇室系统中的王子也实在太多了，无法处理。所以即使是我们自己心爱的王室，这也是一个问题。你会积累王室的杂乱。
You have to get rid of them. I mean, we've discovered that two is too many, basically. Basically, pretty much. And in Kyoto, in the 9th and 10th century, this is even more of a problem. And, you know, these princes clutter up the place and they're very expensive, so you've got to get rid of them. And so the solution is to cut them loose from the imperial family by giving them this special surname. And one of these, as in Lady Mirasaki's novel, is Genji, or as the clan name is more generally known, Minamoto, which is, it means origin. So Genji and Minamoto are basically the same word.
你必须摆脱他们。我的意思是，我们已经发现两个基本上就太多了。基本上，差不多。而在京都，在9世纪和10世纪，这更是一个问题。而且，你知道，这些王子把地方弄得很乱，而且他们非常昂贵，所以你必须摆脱他们。所以解决方案是通过给他们这个特殊的姓氏将他们从皇室中解脱出来。其中之一，正如紫夫人的小说中那样，是源氏，或者正如氏族名称更广为人知的那样，是“源”，意思是起源。所以源氏和源基本上是同一个词。
The other dynasty is the Heke, or as it's more generally known, the Tyra, which means peace. So by the 10th century, these two clans of ex-princes, the Minamoto and the Tyra, have emerged to become two of the greatest dynasties in the empire. And the field of their operations tends to lie in the provinces and potentially. particularly the northeastern provinces in canto and beyond canto. And here, they are very, very glamorous figures because they come trailing clouds of imperial glamour. And they bring with them all kinds of benefits that people out in the wilds can, you know, immediately want. So they can offer kind of high-ranking governorships and military commands. They can offer the local aristocracy's
另一个王朝是平家，或者更广为人知的平氏，意思是和平。所以到了10世纪，这两个前王子氏族，源氏和平氏，已经崛起成为帝国最伟大的两个王朝。他们的行动领域往往在省份，特别是关东及关东以外的东北省份。在这里，他们是非常迷人的人物，因为他们带着皇室的魅力。他们带来了各种各样的人们在荒野中可以，你知道，立即想要的好处。所以他们可以提供高级总督职位和军事指挥权。他们可以提供当地贵族的
marriage into what is a kind of, you know, it gives them a kind of, you know, it gives them a kind of, kind of imperial link. And so lots of these regional dynasties are very, very happy to take on the name of Minamoto or Tyra, because they're much more glamorous than their own. And so the Minamoto and the Tyra become larger and larger as kind of dynastic organizations. And they provide people out in the provinces with this sense that they have a real kind of, a very glamorous link to what is going on in Kyoto, what is going on in the capital. So all of this is looking great. It's all seems fine. It's all taking along. But as you imply Dominic, there is a kind of potential problem here, because what if a Minamoto or a Tyra out in the provinces should start to feel that, you know,
与某种，你知道，它给了他们一种，你知道，它给了他们一种，某种皇室联系。所以许多这些区域王朝非常、非常乐意采用源氏或平氏的名字，因为它们比他们自己的名字迷人得多。所以源氏和平氏作为王朝组织变得越来越大。他们为省份的人们提供了这样一种感觉，即他们与京都正在发生的事情、首都正在发生的事情有着真正的、非常迷人的联系。所以这一切看起来都很棒。一切似乎都很好。一切都在按部就班地进行。但正如你所暗示的，多米尼克，这里有一个潜在的问题，因为如果省里的源氏或平氏开始觉得，你知道，
his nose is being put out of joint, perhaps by the court in Kyoto, perhaps by another member of his clan, perhaps by both. You know, they have warriors at their back. What is to stop them going a little bit rogue? And this. in the 930s is precisely how Tyra no Massacardo. So he is the first samurai, the guy whose head goes flying off after it's been decapitated. This is how he comes to feel. Because he is a Tyra, right? He's from the Tyra clan. Yes, he is. And so he is of imperial descent. But he is very bitterly conscious of being kind of downwardly mobile. Things are not going well for him. So he had been born in the northern reaches of Kanto, this kind of great plain beyond the
他的鼻子被碰歪了，也许是被京都的朝廷，也许是被他氏族的另一个成员，也许两者都有。你知道，他们背后有武士。有什么能阻止他们变得有点流氓呢？而这，在930年代，正是平将门的感受。所以他是第一位武士，那个被斩首后头颅飞走的人。这就是他的感受。因为他是平氏，对吧？他来自平氏家族。是的，他是。所以他是皇室后裔。但他非常痛苦地意识到自己正在某种程度上向下流动。事情对他来说进展不顺利。所以他出生在关东的北部地区，这个将它与京都隔开的巨大平原之外。
mountains that separate it from Kyoto. And he has grown up a very formidable warrior. And as we said, he's absolutely, absolute unit, absolutely huge. He's got his two eyeballs in his left eye. And he has made himself a master of what is described by the samurai as the way of the bow and the horse. In otherwise, he's a great horseman and he can fire a bow sitting in the saddle. It's not enough for Minamoto just to be a warrior because that would mean that he really has kind of gone down socially. He's kind of lost his status. He wants to be doing his calligraphy and his poetry and stuff as well, doesn't he?
他成长为一个非常强大的战士。正如我们所说，他绝对是一个巨人，绝对巨大。他的左眼里有两个瞳孔。他使自己成为武士所描述的“弓马之道”的大师。换句话说，他是一位伟大的骑兵，可以在马背上射箭。对于源氏来说，仅仅成为一名战士是不够的，因为那意味着他真的在社会上走下坡路了。他失去了地位。他想做他的书法和诗歌之类的东西，不是吗？
Kind of, I think by this point, I think he's less interested in that, but he wants the kind of the stamp of authority and glamour that only the Imperial Court ultimately can provide. And so he applies for a government post, a post that will say to everyone around him, yes, I have. imperial favour and he gets turned down. And then he is snubbed by his own uncle, a guy called Tyra Yoshikane. And what Mascado has done is to ask Yoshikane his uncle for his daughter, so his cousin, to be his wife. And Yoshikane says, no, I'm not interested in you. You're just a samurai. You know, you don't really rank as a member of my family anymore. And Massacardo is incredibly insulted by this and goes absolutely berserk. So one minute he is quarreling with Yoshikane about his wedding plan, saying that he, you know, demanding to marry his cousin. And the next, he's been refused by Yoshikane, goes completely ballistic and starts torching entire
某种程度上，我想到了这一点，我想他对此兴趣较小，但他想要那种只有皇室最终才能提供的权威和魅力的印记。所以他申请了一个政府职位，一个会告诉他周围所有人，是的，我有皇室恩宠的职位，但他被拒绝了。然后他被他自己的叔叔，一个叫平良兼的人冷落了。将门所做的是向他的叔叔良兼请求他的女儿，也就是他的表妹，作为他的妻子。而良兼说，不，我对你不感兴趣。你只是一个武士。你知道，你不再算是我家族的一员了。而将门对此感到极其侮辱，并彻底发狂。所以前一分钟他还在和良兼争论他的婚礼计划，说他，你知道，要求娶他的表妹。下一分钟，他被良兼拒绝了，彻底失控，开始焚烧整个
villages simply because these villages are dependencies of one of Yoshikane's allies. And we have a near contemporaneous account. So this isn't kind of written up decades later. This is kind of from around the time. That day, the voice of the flames contended with the thunder, as it echoed, that hour, the colour of the smoke battled with the clouds as it covered the sky. People's homes were turned to ashes and scattered before the winds. Provincial officials and peasants alike beheld it all in anguish. And so Yoshikane obviously is infuriated by this. I mean, insulted. You know, he has to have vengeance. And so he raises an enormous army, which massacado, at the head of only a hundred horsemen, spectacularly routes.
村庄，仅仅因为这些村庄是良兼盟友的附属地。我们有一份近乎同时代的记录。所以这不是几十年后写出来的。这是来自那个时代左右。那天，火焰的声音与雷声争鸣，回荡着，那一刻，烟雾的颜色与云朵搏斗，覆盖了天空。人们的家园化为灰烬，在风中四散。省官员和农民都痛苦地看着这一切。所以良兼显然对此感到愤怒。我的意思是，被侮辱了。你知道，他必须复仇。所以他集结了一支庞大的军队，而将门，仅率领一百名骑兵，就壮观地击溃了他们。
It's an incredible victory, tribute to Massacardo's charisma and to his mastery of the arts of warfare. And so now things really are kicking off. Massacardo has taken his cousin, married her, Yoshikane kidnaps her back. According to the kind of the romantic version of this story, Massacardo then sneaks behind enemy lines to meet her and does so with the connivance of his wife's brothers, also his cousins. So there's a sense there of a kind of, you know, real kind of denastic snarl, romance and hatreds and rivalries and all of that. And this is intensified by the fact that Massacardo's cousin, a very sinister man called
这是一场不可思议的胜利，是对将门魅力和他对战争艺术掌握的致敬。所以现在事情真的开始了。将门带走了他的表妹，娶了她，良兼又把她绑架了回去。根据这个故事的浪漫版本，将门随后潜入敌后去见她，并在他妻子的兄弟们（也是他的表兄弟）的默许下这样做。所以这里有一种，你知道，真正的那种王朝纠葛、浪漫、仇恨和竞争的感觉。而这一点因为将门的表兄弟，一个非常阴险的人，名叫
Sadamori, has signed up to Massacardo's side and then promptly stabbed him in the back, betrayed him, acted as the agent of Yoshikane. And even worse, Sadamori then rushes off to Kyoto, basically to tell tales on Massacardo. And as a reward for this, Sadamori is given the northern command that had been held by Massacardo's father and which Massacardo himself obviously had been hoping to get. So again, it's an incredible insult to Massacardo and makes him even more determined to have his vengeance. And this is a very fateful step because essentially what had begun as a kind of family feud is now starting to embroil the whole of Japan. Massacardo goes even further, doesn't he? doubles down, because this is the point at which he can basically keep gambling or stop,
贞盛，加入了将门的一方，然后立即在背后捅了他一刀，背叛了他，充当了良兼的代理人。更糟糕的是，贞盛随后冲向京都，基本上是去告将门的状。作为奖励，贞盛获得了原本由将门父亲持有，而将门本人显然一直希望获得的北方指挥权。所以这再次是对将门极大的侮辱，使他更加决心复仇。这是一个非常致命的步骤，因为本质上，原本作为一种家族世仇的事情现在开始卷入整个日本。将门走得更远，不是吗？加倍下注，因为这是他基本上可以继续赌博或停止的点，
and he decides to keep gambling, and he makes an extraordinary decision that he is going to declare himself emperor. So this basically takes us to that point I made earlier about, you know, why isn't it like the late Roman Empire, where provincial governors are declaring themselves emperor? Well, now it is, because this is what he's done. I mean, he doesn't declare himself the emperor of Kyoto, so the southwestern half of Japan. He's specifically, specifically, Specifically of Kanto, which is this kind of this great plane. And Massacardo is the first and he will not be the last to recognize that Kanto is actually a much larger lowland region than Kansai, which is the plane on which Kyoto stands. And just to emphasize, Japan is three quarters mountain.
他决定继续赌博，他做出了一个非凡的决定，他要宣布自己为天皇。所以这基本上把我们带到了我之前提到的那一点，关于，你知道，为什么它不像罗马帝国晚期，省长们宣布自己为皇帝？好吧，现在是了，因为这就是他所做的。我的意思是，他并没有宣布自己是京都的天皇，也就是日本西南部的一半。他特别，特别，特别宣布自己是关东的天皇，也就是这片大平原。而将门是第一个，他也不会是最后一个认识到关东实际上是一个比关西（京都所在的平原）大得多的低地地区的人。再次强调，日本四分之三是山地。
So wherever, you know, the planes are absolutely crucial. If you control a large fertile plane, then you, you know, you're really motoring. And because Kanto is larger than Kansai, the plane on which Kyoto stands, then it means that potentially Kanto is a much richer and more powerful region. And even though Kyoto will remain the official capital of Japan for another 1,000 years, in the long run it is Massacardo who will enjoy the last laugh, because today, you know, it's not Kansai, but Kanto, which boasts Japan's and indeed perhaps the world's larger city, and that is the city that comes to be known as Tokyo, the eastern capital.
所以无论在哪里，平原都绝对至关重要。如果你控制了一片肥沃的大平原，那么你，你知道，你真的在飞速发展。而且因为关东比关西（京都所在的平原）大，这意味着关东可能是一个更富裕、更强大的地区。即使京都将在未来1000年里继续作为日本的官方首都，从长远来看，是将门会笑到最后，因为今天，你知道，不是关西，而是关东，拥有日本乃至全世界最大的城市，那就是后来被称为东京的城市，即东都。
So Massacardo, by declaring himself the emperor of Kanto, he is kind of looking to the future, but it is a very distant future. Yeah, not his own future, unfortunately, for him. No, because by doing this, by declaring himself emperor of Kanto, effectively he's signed his own death warrant because the imperial authorities are not going to recognize his rule. It's just unthinkable. And so what they do is, you know, the classic course. They employ rival lords to bring Massacardo down.
所以将门通过宣布自己为关东天皇，他有点展望未来，但这是一个非常遥远的未来。是的，不幸的是，对他来说，不是他自己的未来。不，因为通过这样做，通过宣布自己为关东天皇，他实际上签署了自己的死刑判决书，因为帝国当局不会承认他的统治。这简直是不可想象的。所以他们所做的是，你知道，经典的路线。他们雇佣敌对的领主来打倒将门。
And these rival lords, who include Sadamori, his cousin, are sponsored to turn on Massacardo, and they're given funds that enable them to fight through the winter. And this is something that Massacardo doesn't have. And so he is unable to sustain his own forces through the offseason. And he's cornered. He's shot through the forehead. which is the one bit that his mother, the giant snake, hadn't been able to lick. So it splits his skull.
而这些敌对的领主，包括他的表兄弟贞盛，被赞助去对付将门，他们获得了使他们能够熬过冬天的资金。这是将门所没有的。所以他无法在淡季维持自己的军队。他被逼到了绝境。他被射穿了前额，这是他母亲，那条巨蛇，没能舔到的那一点。所以它劈开了他的头骨。
And then he is decapitated. And his head, of course, is then brought to Kyoto's put on the marketplace. And it probably doesn't go flying off. His fate does serve the Lords of Japan and the samurai class more generally as a salutary warning. And so his career, to that extent, you know, it's the exception that proves the rule. And, you know, several decades after the death of Massacado, the year 1000, this is the period when Lady Murasaki is writing the tale of Genji. So it's 1100 pages long. And warfare in it is barely mentioned.
然后他被斩首了。他的头颅，当然，随后被带到京都，放在市场上。它可能并没有飞走。他的命运确实作为一种有益的警告，服务于日本的领主和更广泛的武士阶层。所以他的职业生涯，在某种程度上，你知道，是证明规则的例外。而且，你知道，在将门死后几十年，公元1000年，这是紫夫人撰写《源氏物语》的时期。所以它有1100页长。其中的战争几乎没有被提及。
And it never intrudes directly. It's the same with the pillow book, isn't it, that we also did, Shea Shonigan's book. I mean, there's basically no fighting, no hint of battles, nothing, no sense of sort of disorder out there. and everything is incredibly ordered and perfect and elegant and all of this kind of thing. And when we did that series on those two writers, we talked about how extraordinary this is in the context of what's going on in Western Europe in the same period. It's Vikings. It's Etheretian Reddy.
它从未直接介入。枕草子也是如此，不是吗？我们之前也做过，清少纳言的书。我的意思是，基本上没有战斗，没有战斗的暗示，什么都没有，没有那种混乱的感觉。一切都极其有序、完美、优雅，所有这些东西。当我们制作关于那两位作家的系列节目时，我们谈到了在同一时期西欧发生的事情的背景下，这是多么非凡。那是维京人。那是埃塞尔雷德。
It's massacres. It's people, bishops being hit over the head with hammers. It's just completely different. Yeah. Whereas in the tale of Genji, it's not just that people aren't talking about war. They're not even talking about warriors. There are no worries. They just don't feature.
那是大屠杀。那是人们，主教被锤子敲打头部。这完全不同。是的。而在《源氏物语》中，不仅仅是人们不谈论战争。他们甚至不谈论武士。根本没有武士。他们根本不出现。
For people living in the court, this is a kind of paradisal age of peace and tranquility. And they are so secluded from the violence and the vulgarity of the provinces that they can enjoy the fruits of this brilliant civilization without having to worry about war. It's a world of beauty, of poetry, of love, of exquisite, calligraphy, beautiful perfumes. You know, if you're into that kind of thing, it's tremendous. However, you know, history does not come to an end. We see that for ourselves. And so it is for the courtiers in Hayankyo in Kyoto, because beyond the mountains which ring the capital, the samurai are still very much there. And they are still learning the way of the bow and the horse. and they're still being hired by governors of distant provinces as private mercenaries and being
对于生活在朝廷里的人来说，这是一个和平与安宁的乐园时代。他们与省份的暴力和粗俗隔绝，以至于他们可以享受这种辉煌文明的果实，而不必担心战争。这是一个充满美、诗歌、爱情、精致书法、美丽香水的世界。你知道，如果你喜欢那种东西，那真是太棒了。然而，你知道，历史并没有终结。我们自己也看到了这一点。对于平安京（京都）的朝臣们来说也是如此，因为在环绕首都的山脉之外，武士们仍然在那里。他们仍然在学习弓马之道。他们仍然被遥远省份的总督雇佣为私人雇佣兵，并被
enrolled as their own retainers as samurai, and still very much on the scene, and in fact, more powerful, more ambitious, more restless than ever, are these two great dynasties derived from the imperial house, the Tyra and the Minamoto. And Dominic, it may not have been evident to the silken, aristocrats cloistered in Kyoto, but the storm clouds of war were building. And the war that will come, this is a war that is going to end forever the dominance of the imperial court and establish in its place a dramatically new order because the age of the courtier is coming to an the age of the samurai is dawning.
招募为他们自己的随从，作为武士，而且仍然在现场，事实上，比以往任何时候都更强大、更有野心、更不安分，这就是这两个源自皇室的伟大王朝，平氏和源氏。多米尼克，对于那些在京都深宫里的丝绸贵族来说，这可能并不明显，但战争的乌云正在聚集。而即将到来的战争，这是一场将永远结束皇室统治，并建立一个截然不同的新秩序的战争，因为朝臣的时代即将结束，武士的时代正在黎明。
What a cliffhanger. So we'll be returning to this brewing rivalry between the Tyra and the Minamoto in the next episode in which the age of the samurai dawns in earnest. Now, if you want to hear that next episode literally right now, you can, if you're a member of the Restis History Club, because you've got it already. In fact, you don't just have to listen to that episode. The next two episodes in this series are available to members of the Restis History Club. club as well. If you want to join that particular samurai war band and hear those episodes, then head
真是个悬念。所以我们将在下一集中回到平氏和源氏之间酝酿的竞争，那一集武士时代将正式开启。现在，如果你想立刻听到下一集，如果你是Restis历史俱乐部的成员，你就可以听到，因为你已经拥有了它。事实上，你不必只听那一集。本系列的接下来两集也提供给Restis历史俱乐部的成员。如果你想加入那个特定的武士战团并收听这些剧集，那就前往
to the rest is history.com. And you get all kinds of unbelievable benefits as well, including our exciting super-soreway new newsletter, which has all kinds of extra content about the samurai and their age. So, on that bombshell, Tom, alagatukazimas, and sayonara, everybody. Matane. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
therestisistory.com。你还可以获得各种令人难以置信的好处，包括我们令人兴奋的超级新通讯，其中包含关于武士及其时代的所有额外内容。那么，带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，阿里嘎多，再见，各位。回头见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。